plus heureux pour toi ma fille et pour
les plus jeunes
albert millaire c'est antoine hamelin
dans la série mémoire vive pendant cinq
ans jusqu'en décembre dernier il a joué
le rôle d'un pédiatre à la retraite il
est le père de claire radio oncologues
jouée par marie thérèse fortin est si mi
temps d'avoir en face de soi
le grand albert millaire quelques crêpes
parce que jouer avec quelqu'un qui est
qu'ils portent telle histoire ses
grandes figures l'aude c'est toujours
ont toujours impressionné mais en même
temps il faut que tu joues comme si
c'était ton passé c'était assez
particulier pour moi de rentrer dans
cette zone délimitée là avec lui mais il
rendait toujours les choses très fortes
[Musique]
la comédienne se souvient en particulier
de la scène où son père se marie
pour s'apprécier c'est ce que je
chantais dans la seine ce qu' ils
étaient contents ils trouvaient la
sanguine écrite il l'aimé beaucoup et
était contente de pouvoir tourner cette
scène là avec moi il me faisait sentir
ça c'était c'est un beau cadeau si on
est un peu moins jeunes on se rappelle
aussi qu albert millaire a fait de la
publicité à la télévision des slogans
imprégnées à jamais dans nos cerveaux
lorette
c'est un peu plus cher mais c'est plus
que du bonbon clarette à montlieu la
jeunesse le rend peut-être un peu vite
mais ça lui passera ici on a la chance
d'être encore moins jeunes on a vu
albert millaire à son apogée à la
télévision par exemple me série où il
joue le premier ministre wilfrid laurier
de devenir candidat libéral dans la
belle et surtout surtout d'iberville une
série de 39 épisodes où il tient le rôle
titre de sueur pierre le moyne
d'iberville de l' aventure des combats
contre les anglais les hollandais qui
nous a tenus en haleine par écoutait
religieusement ça et j'écoutais savent
écrire parce que ça c'est les capes et
d'épées pistes et toutes les piles et
pisteurs beau bonhomme tout le monde en
convient mais nul n'est contredit albert
millaire c'est d'abord une personne de
théâtre un des véritables pionniers du
théâtre québécois
il a joué les grandes pièces du
répertoire classique tartuffe hamlet le
misanthrope cyrano de bergerac ce que
vous faites une et la vapeur du tabac
vous sortent ailes du nez sans qu'un
voisin écrire ou feu de cheminée
il a joué tous les rôles et occuper
aussi tous les postes albert millaire a
aussi été metteur en scène auteur
directeur de compagnie théâtrale marie
thérèse contre elle l'a eu comme metteur
en scène au théâtre du trident à québec
il ya près de 30 ans était très exigeant
mais était très encourageant même temps
puis c'est comme ces commentaires
étaient toujours très constructif le
jeune homme au regard une carrière qui
s'étale sur des décennies
il a fallu s'adapter jouer un
propriétaire de galeries d'art des
paroles et de la consommation de
marijuana
sais tu ce que j'ai fait quand j'ai
repris ma fille claire avec ça ça lui a
d'ailleurs valu un gémeaux du meilleur
rôle de soutien masculin en 2014
au début des années 2000 un cancer le
force à suspendre sa carrière
moi je me suis dis merci d'avoir une
facture cacher un souper de famille
jacques il reprend progressivement le
travail le antoine hamelin de mémoire
vive sera son dernier grand rôle et
était très heureux qu'on leur demande en
berne
et comme c'était une grande saga
familiale à faire leurs limites et très
simple il aimait dans l'exceptionnel sur
le plateau le plateau lui rendais bien
parce qu'on était vraiment très bon
albas de la classe à tous points de vue
c'était la classe de la classe jusqu'à
la fin baisser de rideau à 83 ans à la
maison entourée de ses proches
[Musique]